foreign
yes so thank you everyone for coming
this morning I think I have the
microphone on
so it's all good
so I'm going to give a
kind of a survey of the state of the art
of lower bounds on proof complexity via
algebraic circuit complexity
not all of it are going to be just the
lower bounds but I'm going to show you
something quite interesting I think or
maybe even very interesting let's
discuss this at the end is that what
happens
in recent years is that a lot of open
problems that we are basically open
Major open problems in
proof complexity or Boolean from vexity
and proof complexity from the
perspective of frag proof system logical
proof systems are actually solved in the
algebraic world and I'll show you what I
mean and let's see uh precisely what are
these results and what do they mean for
proof complexity and discuss a bit of
open problems in the frontiers of uh
first of this approach and also how to
actually leverage this approach to the
traditional open problems of proof
complexity this is a these are open
problems
so this is going to connect both proof
complexity people interested in uh
mostly strong proof system frege
[Music]
ac0 fragrance so forth but also it's
going to be tailored for people in
algebraic complexity there are several
here and I'll give some detail of some
of the results in algebraic complexity
and so let me repeat what we've uh
usually doing in proof complexity we are
doing a
oh the clicker is here
so what we are doing in proof complexity
um for most part is the following uh
simple question
given a proof system P other hard
instances now hard instances so I'm
going to do it quickly this means that
these are tautologies such the T the
proof system doesn't have a short this
is a short proof does not have a short
proof of this tautology Tau
which simply means that these that there
does not exist P proof of Tau of size
polynomial in the size of the formula
right
major uh that's the the
main question of proof complexity right
and Cook's program
uh which is in some sense a program uh
Yankovic told us about this program and
cast doubt about uh
the fact that it is it was a program
um
I think it is in some sense still uh
undertones all research in proof
complexity so it is a program it's just
that practically in uh in science or in
this branch of science people do not
formally say this is a program so nobody
is going to say this is a program but
definitely this undertones and this is
uh
the idea behind the proof complexity so
and this is the following if for all
proof system p
there are hard instances
than NP is unequal to Coen p and whole
also p is n equal to NP so in some limit
ideal case it means that proof
complexity
um is taking us step by step towards the
versus NP in this sense
so
what are the major open problems in
complex improve complexity or some of
them so hard instances for strong
group systems
so we know these uh classical result by
itai and then
so uh
let's see and Patrick Woods in public
or ac0 Frederick lower bound so yeah
to cover all the basic definition
so
other hard instances for strong proof
system Beyond this
so this is uh the major the major
problems then it is open now we
sometimes want also to ask the following
okay we cannot prove this hard the hard
instances for proof complexity exist but
maybe conditional proof complexity lower
bounds exist maybe we can prove for
strong proof systems for instance
computational lower bound imply some
extended fragment I denote EF lower box
computational here means something
different than NP is unequal to co-n-p
which is
this this implication
it means that EF is has hard instance
so this is the question
traditional bonds and something slightly
more specific than this we want to ask
whether we have a very tight connection
between circuit complexity and proof
system so do we have this kind of result
circuit lower bounds implies strong uh
proof system lower bars
also mostly open there are a lot of
results here in the regime of weak proof
systems that I have learned uh specified
precisely the maybe the most prominent
is the interpolation technique that
we've already heard of
uh so and that's why I put here this
opponents known for proof system with uh
one of the unfeasible interpolation
where we use uh Circuit look Monon
circuit load bound to get group systems
by reduction from approval small proof
to a small monotone circuit and because
we already know monotone circuit law
bounds by rasborough and
Etc we get lower bars but these are in
the regime of the week proof system
okay
uh there is this um
uh there is this point about uh
non-community formulas lower bounds for
uh and this is the point it's a circuit
lower bound but it's for a family of in
some sense semi-defined polynomials
would imply already strong proof system
law about this is also in this algebraic
approach it's a result with the lien one
uh but I'm not going to cover this one
so this this shows something about this
circuit lower bound implied proofs but
it's not I wouldn't say it's direct as
we want it's not a precise law about
it's a lower bound on uh on some family
about what is semi-defined phenomena
yeah the semi-defined that Nest means
simply that it's a family of that in the
that precisely Define the
so-called IPS
certificate
in the non-community so basically it's a
sorry
yes but the IPS low bound is a
polynomial and we can characterize this
polynomial we don't know precisely which
polynomial we know it's a family of
polynomials that produce this IPS
certification
[Music]
this result
um conversely does strong proof of
brexity low bond is my computational
so for instance does ef lower bound
extended fragrance
does not have small circuits
so in some sense Cook's program realized
already with this is how I write with if
you see with extended fragrance so uh
Jan pick talked about this yesterday uh
and
basically
his work with Rahul tried to uh
would imply uh complexity
uh these and yams and rahul's result
were uh condition
um right of course in the weak regime
with proof system regime some results
for uh resolution to monotone circuits
are known
I think one paper is gargoose kamat and
Sakura
you have this kind of ideas again in the
week which is proof systems uh there
might be other
I mean it's it's a it's a it's a well
thought about question so there might be
other
um
so I'm going to produce a solution now
of course in Brackets
and the solution to all these major
problems can be done uh
swallows
we can expand the language of
unsatisfiable forms
if we expand the language
to still a natural language a co-op
language in the following sense and this
is a traditional thing it's a it's a
natural expansion it's not something
unique uh it's the following so let's
assume we have this proof systems
usual one unsatisfiable formulas with uh
histological Gates and or not right
CNF and so forth
and we have the usual proof system
resolution fragrance so forth for
propositional tautologies in this
language
let's expand it a bit a bit to include
also sets of polynomial equations over
some field you choose some fixed field
find that field
with no zero one Solutions so it's
important that it's not zero one
solution so it's still propositional
so
and this was for instance an example
just a linear
unsatisfiable equation over large enough
field
so
you see
this is
the language that we use in algebraic
proof complexity or algebraic proof
systems the traditional one PCA
polynomial calculus new standings ads
and so forth and indeed the original
results were on this kind of uh
algebraic instances not CNF instances
um digital principle and so forth so
this is the language we work with
not just cnfs or Boolean formulas but
sets of polynomial equations over uh
over a field with no zero one Solutions
and it's still a co-np set because of
the zero one
so we can check if it says
uh we'll check if a solution is
weaknesses satisfied with it
right
so this is a very natural extension
so it can be even considered not as As
Natural as CNF and in this regime we
actually when proof systems are approved
for this language expanded language I'm
going to show you that uh a lot of uh
the major open problems
are actually sold
to a certain degree of
something special
um correct and these are the proof
system that are interested in this
regime polynomial calculus polynomial
calculus with resolution nulls tenens
ads and what I'm going to discuss today
mostly is IPS ideal proof system
um
so here is a sketch of
the proof system map we've seen it in uh
so
it's slightly not all of the of the
proof systems are there because I want
to restrict uh our interests not to semi
algebraic proof system just to be budget
right and propositional
so here are a system for propositional
logic resolution constant depth extended
frege and this means uh this is stronger
than this one this zero
and and so these are the propositional
logic
goes from weak strong and well I said
here it's very strong
and here in this more yellow region it's
is a proof system for logic but also for
algebraic uh for systems of equations
overfilled with uh zero one variables
right
polynomial calculus and IPS
now
as I said we should see that the open
problems mentioned before have solution
for IPs I'm going to Define it where the
hard instances are non-boolia
[Music]
it is zero for one value but for
instance it's not going to be a CNF or a
formula it's going to be a function
maybe or a polynomial or a linear form
where when you plug in 0 1 you still get
many values one two three four you
cannot do it
to the series
so here is ideal proof system
uh introduced by Rojo and pitasi this is
the journal version
so basically this ID of Ideal group
system
was circulating it mostly initiated I
would say in 96 by Tony Tony speaks
these ideas of thinking about the
complexity of proof system via algebraic
circuit size instead of Boolean cities
at some crucial uh crucial idea here
that I will show you that made it
possible to do it more elegantly and
have some nice results so
here is the ideal proof system it's a
very strong one a proof system for the
language that we are interested in
okay these polynomials be multivariate
with let's say m variables X1 to xn FY
F1 to FM
in this ring
of a field
so important now which one but we have
to fix it uh over filled f with no zero
one solution so yes zero one Solutions
means that this means that there is an
equation here with zero all of these
need to be zero
so there is no way to uh
satisfy all of these equations with the
zero
so a refutation is the following term
it's just a sum a polynomial sum of the
X
so these are the axioms F1 to FM they
are unsatisfiable over zero one so I
will also add these what I call Boolean
axioms x 1 squared minus X1
also over 0 1 it means that every
solution uh that uh every solution
should satisfy this one
um
and I'm going to have this
so this sum says
for some polynomials I just choose the
polynomial G1 to GM I multiply them by
the axioms and then I choose
also other polynomials
H1 to h n and multiply these Boolean
axioms
right
so you see every term here every
summoned is a multiplication of one
Axiom and some arbitrary polynomial that
I choose for my proof and I'm going to
say it is one namely one here is
polynomial identity
if it's important it's not one as a
function it's actually it actually means
that
this polynomial when you uh multiply out
all the brackets and so forth that sum
everything all the monomials are zero
except the constant monomial and it is
one
technical support
and
by the way how do you check this
you will also explained to us you know
this is solution so this is simply uh
this proof system cannot be checked and
is not known to be checkable in uh uh
group and not known to be checkable in
polynomial time deterministic you need
the probability so you do it with
responsible
so it's Pro RP I wrote it in the next
it's not important for us
um right this is a bit a smartphone but
the soundness is easy right
this sound because if you have a proof
uh then it must be unsatisfiable
otherwise you can get here one
and completeness well two proofs are
possible here or maybe more one is
Hilbert that's this is how it was
conceived in the 90s by
uh
um
yeah so a cry check good luck
in 94 90 something
so this is the Gilbert nordstrances but
we don't need this fancy uh
geometry we can just have a constructive
argument because we have these Boolean
axioms we can go by induction on n
that's something that's not it's not
necessary for us
so IPS ideal proof system
oh so what did I say here yeah well I
still didn't Define the idea proof
system I defined this term
this is the notion of that and now I'm
going to discuss the ideal proof system
now with some cardiac I'm going to use
what is called actually linear IPS
because here I'm not going to have these
multiply themselves
so the same thing FIS are a set of
polynomials which is not solution and
the refutation is this and now so I took
this and I put a box a red box here and
this is the idea of growth of potassium
we take these
these axioms
and change them into wise and that's
new variables
that's the main idea instead of
instead of thinking of this as a term
now we're going to plug in these
variables instead of these guys and what
do we get we get the polynomial a single
polynomial such that
this is what is
happening I don't know if it's uh it
might be able to
foreign
so
oh
so you see this and now you get this
polynomial we get that this and these
are the now the
variables that I substituted here
and so this is actually now a polynomial
a single polynomial it's not a family of
polynomials anymore it's a single
polynomial each proof is a single
polynomial in uh these very formal
variables x y and z
that is the placeholder variables
because then we plug in the axioms and
we get the following so let's call this
polynomial C
with the displayed variable X Y and Z
and when we plug in 0 for the Y's and Z
of course we get zero because
of this right because this is how it is
defined which means that we work in the
ideal generated by the accents facing
the second condition is then when we
plug in the axions it is 1.
h
yeah yeah
yes sorry
about requiring the gist to be given the
nature be given by seconds
so you say that okay let's test the same
thing this is a typo so it should be
these sorry
um
and you while asked whether
because I said that these cannot
multiply themselves so I said it's
linear IPS a new market it's a identical
to General
no I'm saying that you can ask and stand
for the gis and the G's and ages has
been giving us a list of coefficients
has been driven by circuits is this the
same system no it's not the same circuit
I still didn't finish my definition the
system if it's given by
at least
sure yes it's going to be a genetic let
me justify
yes
so again this is polynomial identities
uh and yeah maybe I should so I guess
the question is like are there
restrictions on what's the health C can
be represented
it uh and this is the Restriction IPS is
measured by so for now it's just a c but
RBS is measured by size of algebraic
service
so this is the size that I'm going to
make but I want to uh I want to somehow
disassociated from the definition
because I can say this is a proof C is a
proof it's just a polynomial single
polynomial and now I'm going to change
it's going to be a model where to finish
it I'm just going to change this the
size measure so I'm going to say the
size of the IPS is measured by algebraic
statements but now I'm going to say
maybe from cells and restricted plus
constant deaths so that's why I said it
like this but everyone is right so IPS
is measured by size
500 by a second then because we are
going to have a lot of talks about on
July complexity juicer I'm going to
briefly again Define this antibiotic
circuits is just that directed at cyclic
graph with edges directed from leaves to
Roots such that we have internal nodes
plus and times
and leaves are filled element or input
variables
something like this each node computes
the corresponding addition or times of
the two polynomial in its
tables
yeah yeah
yeah correct so you're right I didn't
say this explicitly
so yeah the point is that I I wanted to
circumvent this and just show people
this but actually let's forget about
this
fencing definition and just concentrate
on this
so because this is like the usual news
channels but indeed the general circuit
case is identical but let's just talk
about this one because this would be
helpful in our approved
um so I'm just going to sum the sizes of
these H and G's
for someone
and this is under my second size is
number of notes
um
so IPS reputation oh we discuss this and
size and that's what I wanted to say
it's just the size of this gi's and H
eyes again forgetting about this CI the
C is it
it's
now this is
now let's see what we have so as I
claimed before open problems in the
Boolean proof complexity of register
groups actually have Solutions in this
algebraic world when we expand the
language to non-cnf instances
open yeah so let's see this this is open
in the Boolean world what I've discussed
before conditional proof complexity low
balance against strong proof systems
for instance some computational load
bound different than Co-op
lies some strong proof system extended
fragrance
open here and this is in some sense so
by this so this was the result with the
Alexia of Gregory have been here
so it shows the following if we if we
take for
I think I wrote it correctly here uh
it's quite small if we have we assume
this hypothesis from algebraic
complexity that there are no uh poly
logarithmic
size algebraic circuits Computing
multiplication of factorials
and here it's algebraic circuits only
with constants on the leaves and the
constants are one zero and minus one so
you build a constant
on the these this number you want to
build it with plus and times and at the
end it evaluates to this number
for the application of factorial and if
we assume that for these kind of numbers
we don't have a small size algebraic
circuit in this sense
and this is the shoot snail hypothesis
it's still it's not true
it's open if we assume this then we
actually get a solution to this problem
no polynomial size IPS here it's over Q
refutation of this simple instance this
instance is what we call the binary
value principle it just uh
these are zero one variables
and this gives us uh
and this is the the bits of a number and
this is the value of the bit string of
the binary number and we say here it is
unequal to minus one it's equal to 1
minus one which is impossible
um
so you see that this is already
some advancement
of course
well I will talk about a bit about the
cabinets here
about the coefficients here are being
so
let's go for the next one
the open problem in the Boolean world
circuit lower bounds
imply some strong proof system loadbacks
so actually we know this in some sense
there is also a capital
GP is unequal to vnp
which is a computational lower bound
saying that the permanent polynomial
doesn't have polynomial size circuits
here it's over finite fields
if this is true
then we know that there are no
polynomial size IPS refutations of a
certain specific CNF
speaking
so we get this the thing that we want in
the Boolean case that
was from uh computational lower bounds
or complexity class separation implies
strong uh proof complexity level
this is a result with santanam this is
of a finite field
and the caveat here is that this is uh
this is true no polynomial size
refutation of this cnf5 only that we are
not sure that this far is actually
unsatisfied
so we know that it doesn't have short
proofs but it might be just do not have
proof but if it has a proof
or mutation it's not true
well I mean
it's clearly if yeah
you I mean a VP is equal to vnp it
clearly can't have a proof right so
um
that's not the point
but
oh but um
so it is is it in a stronger sense that
you don't know
oh yeah it might be that VP is unequal
to vnp this is correct but we just have
a short purpose right but yeah just the
statement that you don't know that it's
anyway yeah okay yeah so
uh so this is fire so this was kind of a
diagonalization of it so but this is a
CNN which is nice
uh
I'm sorry but the system cannot prove
that the sum of you know like these
non-negative numbers is not negative but
somehow
why you know so what are the odds that
it could prove something like he's not
equal right
you understand it right I mean but you
know why would we be looking at
sentences like you know it cannot prove
that b is not equal to NP if it can't
prove that
I don't know if that's a fair question
but uh yeah so the answer is
yes so you're it's it's it's it's I I
would say it's uh it's not a correct
question in the following sense if
indeed
from this you will already know that
this CNF is unprovable then we would get
uh
then we will get also and this is a CNF
what I said before then we will get
stronger for complexity it simulates
other code systems
IPS simulates other good systems so yes
the extended more depends on the degree
of phrase so this is a non-cnf but for
cnfs we don't know uh
so uh horses
and that's the shoots male hypothesis
implied with me I'm equal to vnp
I think
I say you don't see it as if it's a
result by also Burgess depends on and
also the originals yes
absolutely
[Music]
oh and of course
so I now we flip the direction and we
have this open problem in the Boolean
world that's strong proof complexity
lower bounds inclined computational
problems we have no problems imply for
instance maybe such is known in business
spawning
um
so and this is uh in the algebraic world
it's actually been settled in the
following sense if there is no
polynomial IPS reputation of some CNN
file
doesn't matter which one then grow
chocolatey original work showed that
yeah it should be unsatisfied with him
yes of uh of some anti-respectives
so this is unsatisfiable of course sorry
but then a VP is unable to be okay
is
and this was done by virtual capacity
um
yeah basically the argument was a truth
table
um argument showing the following every
CNF has a truth table simple IPS
refutation
going over all the uh Simon more or less
like Yuval did summing up everything and
this certificate is exponential size but
it's actually computable in vnp right so
because every CNF has a vnp uh IPS
certificate if you have a lower bound
you have separated vnp from you
for CNN not forever
I don't uh prove this
now we go to the more uh
say algebraic slash combinatorial meet
this unconditional proof complexity
level for small group system so we've
seen this uh open problems in the bunion
World which are in some structural uh
questions about conditional results that
are in some sense settled to a certain
degree in the algebraic world and now
I'm going to show the part instances
actually exist in this world
so the first one of course is
it's not precisely in the IPS but I
should mention this it's in the proof
system that is PC Plus some extension
very
extension variables sorry not extension
next sorry
well these are axioms also but extension
variables
but uh let's call it like this P plus PA
so PC PC Plus EA plus extension
variables uh is polynomially strong um
uh equal or stronger than extended for
again
yeah that's correct
because PC
uh with extended variables is already
simulates a resolution with extended
equivalent no
oh it depends on the on the field
no it's not it's dependent on the
language also this is for cnfs and this
is oh I say for CNF are the equivalent
probably yes correct
that what is the
other what's the degree
yes I think it is fine
so
right so this is easy like resolution
plus plus extension variable already
simulates extended phrases so so I'm
just giving you this because I want to
show that it's very strong groups
now Alexia have been 21 showed basically
a similar ideas to the work with the
alexiev hirs in gregoria he showed
unconditionally now that if you take
this binary value principle it does not
have short proof uh uh sorry I shouldn't
say this it might have short proofs that
just the proofs have coefficients which
are so big so when you compute the bit
size of it they become super polynomial
s
so so oh so the magnitude is uh yes two
to the two yeah sorry
thank you very much
so it's a super exponential magnitude so
the sum its size is uh
foreign
consistent a very natural uh hard
instance and it doesn't have small uh
bit size of proofs but some ants
satisfactory parts are these are very it
it builds on the fact that these are
very large
coefficients and also the proof might be
short in the number of steps but just
very big to run the coefficients are
very good is this normal but there is a
short proof
let's try to see some of this uh let's
try to see the template of the lower
Bound for IBS so we call IPS reputation
is like this and this is Blacklist and
the size is a total circuit size of
these GIS and agents
so now as I said we can consider the
different circuit classes read once the
ABCs multilinear formulas for those who
want your body complexity you know these
constant depth circuits and for each of
these circuit classes we already know
unconditional lower bounds
for the circuit class
now I'm going to use it based on the
lower bound template
well I'm not going to show all of this
but it was possible to it is possible to
use uh the the reduction from
um
proof complexity lower bound to
algebraic complexity lower bound it is
possible to show to use these circuit uh
lower bounds to lower bound the size of
IPS
region with this circuit cluster
for each of these cases
I want to show the similar case read
once maybe
so
so let's see how we do the template for
the lower bar so
take a single and this is crucial you
need to take a single
a single Axiom
single zero one unsatisfiable axial f x
equals zero
and then you do the following tree let's
assume we have a proof
this is a polynomial identity right so
all the coefficients are you can still
except the constant
so let's assume I have this one and I
have a single Axiom unsatisfiable accent
this is unsatisfiable over zero one
and then
I do the following I know that g times f
equals 1 over the Boolean U
now it's already not polynomial identity
now it's a functional identity
I just restricted to zero one and that's
why I took out this event
functional
yes so this is g equals 1 over f
oh
of course you just shifted up they
basically just accidentally shifted off
the P of x equals one over f of x yeah
but uh
yeah so I just wanted to say here this
should be this guy so f a x is
unsatisfied equals zero unsatisfiable so
this is not zero so this is okay
because this is never Z
now let's pick some circuit Class C
that's the second class that we want to
work against in the IPS in this case it
will be read one's abilities
so if not polynomial Computing 1 over F
over the Boolean Cube has small circuit
in our class with once adps for instance
we are done
that's the lower bar so we made a very
simple reduction to a circuit lower
bound it's not algebraic usual algebraic
they get low bonds we need here the
functional load box
so we need here this is a family of
polynomials Computing
evaluating to this over zero one but
it's a family because of a non-zero one
values they may be different we don't
know how they react how they behave
this is
okay so what we've seen now is we
reduced C IPS for circuit Class C and
we'll we'll take a read once adps
to the problem prove that no polynomial
G such that this over 0 1 is in class C
and fortunately
we can prove such lower bounds
function in the functional
approach to algebraic circuit robot
and then basically we finish
will you tell us which function yes oh
the function right yeah I'll I'll tell
you but the the function f you mean yes
so basically F unfortunately it's only a
single one
and it's always going to be as of now
some kind of subset sum instance with
some lifting maybe you you take a sum of
x's equals
sum of N axis equals n plus one it's
unsatisfiable
and then you want to lift it if you
wanted more uh complicated circuit
classes so you say x i y i or x i y i z
i and so forth that is always like this
yeah that's the one obstacle to overcome
so
um here is the simplest example I think
this will be more to the Enterprise
models so for them it's going to be very
simple it's just read once oblivious
algebraic pension problem programs this
is the circuit class that we can already
prove law about IPS lower bounds
I see IPS lower boundary so weird ones
roabps are just these guys this is just
a algebraic branching program if you
start from a root and we multiply all
the passes up to the sink and here we
sum all the patterns
each
we have edges
which are polynomials
which are multivariate polynomials not
necessarily multilinear
sorry a univariate polynomials not
necessarily
[Music]
so univariate polynomial and
here we have X1 X2 until xn each
variable is queried once in each layer
here
each layer has only one variable
and it doesn't repeat and
the the variable doesn't repeat and you
have an order so X1 to xn
and that's the model
now the width here
is the maximum number of nodes in a
layer
let's say that the width of this
computational model is this
so
uh so the functions needed to be uh
linear but you're looking at the
behavior on the Boolean Cube so isn't it
without loss of generality we can
linearize
not everything if it's uh you might have
a mo you might have uh
no it's not it's not possible
multi-linear
well not all cases if it's just a
formula how would you multi-linear
but Russell's talking about this case oh
this bit yes
I'm not going to show all the details
but
um
okay so let's see this quickly size of a
read once ABP Computing G this is just a
general statement for example
is bigger is at least the width of this
with one side of the Computing G of
course
and this is at least
basically Nissan 91 the maximal of the
round of the if coefficient Matrix of G
something to understand here so what is
the I coefficient Matrix of G
that's the basic uh primitive for lower
Bound in algebraic complexity if you
think about G ASAP as a vector of
coefficients and you put the monomials
right and you have
X1 to xn and you put the monomial if you
are in the is coefficient Matrix
you put the monomials from variables X1
to x i all the possible monomials here
and all the possible monomials from X
oh here it should be I plus one
and for and and
until xn are here
so you partition it in I and you just
variables until I and this is from I
plus 1 to 1.
and now this is a matrix and in the
m n entry you simply put the coefficient
of this monomial engine
or
and you have a scalar Matrix here
and this is a very useful
because if you think about the rank of
this Matrix
and you take the maximum one over the I
you get the this already the width is
lower bounded by this
it's possible to show it's not hard
I recommend the reading Mr 91 paper it's
a classic and simple
um now here is the trick this will be
quite maybe it's slightly confusing for
those who didn't see these ideas it's
not complicated again so
the same as before
signs of read once ABP Computing G is
low bounded by this is this and actually
this is this rank of five coefficient
Matrix of G
is equivalent to the dimension of the
well I don't include here one eyes the
dimension of the space of rows as
polynomials in this so let's assume we
fixed time
so space of rows as polynomials in
in this polynomial
so uh
so I think of the polynomials here I
just take a row here
so it's basically a polynomial in this
so you can show this it's easy that's
equivalent and basically well that's the
same as the columns
and and this is a trick of I think uh
from 2012.
you can think about the following and
you can lower bound this by the
dimension of evaluation points or
evaluation
polynomials which are evaluated in some
points over the in our case it would be
the Boolean Cube so you take the Boolean
Cube for n minus I so all the
polynomials you you have in these
variables
right and you plug in zero ones instead
of the x i plus 1 1 to X and variables
plugin
elements from the Boolean Cube
and you get a set of polynomials and the
dimension of the span of this or the
dimension of this set
is going to a a lower bound this damage
that's a trick of
this result
and it's not hard to see also
now this trick is very useful because
what we've done here is this is for
polynomial and now we switch to a
measure that measures uh only points on
zero one
it's better for us now because we are in
the functional frame
so right it remains to lower Bound for
some g equals 1 over F over the Boolean
Cube
this
so we've reduced a IPS lower Bound for
read once ADP IPS to this algebraic
problem of lower bounding this
and this is
quite easy
well I cannot cover all of this but
proving this is easy and let me tell you
very briefly the gist here is the ID
idea so proof degree so we need to prove
a slightly better degree than
ipso putlocker99
so they prove the N over 2 low Bound for
a degree of PC we want new standards as
a degree which is precisely n
for these G so we can do this so if G is
and this is this is our hard instance
right and this is one over hard instance
so if we have G that computes this over
0 1 we can show that this as a
multilinear polynomial is of degree
precisely n
that's not complicated to show and then
we're going to lift this degree lower
bound
in in this dimension
argument we're going to show that the
dimension of G when you plug in for the
betas elements from the Boolean cube is
and this is just by the definition
because this is G
and because this is when we plug in y's
into
which are 0 1 we're going to eliminate
all the Y's and we're going to survive
only some of the X's are going to
survive and these are some sums partial
sums of the N variables but we just show
that these must have
as multilinear polynomials maximal
degree
so if X1 X2 X3 survive it must be that
the monomial X1 times X2 times X3 is
here and then it's it's simple to show
and lower terms in some monomial
ordering and you get basically that the
dimension of this is 2 to the n
so that was the trick I did it quite
quick and it's not very complicated but
you need to be for the people in
algebraic complexity I'm sure that they
are quite uh comfortable with this but
for those improve complexity they need
to just uh take some time to see how it
goes but it's not complicated
you need another lift uh degree three so
X1 X2 X1 times times y1 times Z
you do something because uh the degree
is different you have to read the uh
forms and all data yeah so here it is so
uh cibs lower bounds grid ones ADP is
formulas as having as slightly
differently and constant depth circuit
so these these two classes uh flow Bound
for CIP is very important
and make the sound and this is also of
course using browse and rather new dial
and this is a new paper by with the
echovin the Sami and hakoneumi
and we use the limaya stripping
assignment of Ms low bound to get
constant depth circuit IPS lower bounds
with some curvier that the polynomial
IPS is actually multi-linear
for some technical reasons
uh okay so we didn't get much to the
open problems but the open problems are
obvious how to get this to the CNF
region
well nobody knows is it possible we
don't know uh
okay for IPs if we can do CNF Global for
IPs we get sloban for extended fragrance
so it would be quite impressive but also
we get vpvnp so it's quite challenging
test
but for constant apps ipf IPS I think
there is still hope
uh we have constant depth IPS lower
bounds for Big Field a large enough
build and I think it should it may help
in this local tc0 regular bound and so
forth or ac0p fragile lower bound if we
get the CNF
uh and some intermediate problems of
course take out the single exit to have
not just single Axiom part but two next
but of course there are some very
trivial
two action cases which are uninteresting
you have to think carefully what do you
think what is actually an interesting
case of more than one exit
final field case also important
everything here was for a large enough
case because we need for instance
unsatisfiable subset sum it wouldn't
work for the final case
and also because of formality theorem
this functional robot wouldn't work but
that's that's the symmetry so just
finish with some polemics
uh perhaps we shouldn't really insist on
CNF or bully and hard instances and I
ask you
we have this there is the problems are
solved why do you think CNF are more
natural important than these very
natural uh
enhances
now some people might say okay we
already have these results I think it's
by all of them and our office for tqba
if we expand our language
then we get this kind of solution to
problems in proof complexity and also if
we have some first order logic this is
the free demand results uh and I think
good luck but these are not co-edp
languages here we are dealing with a
simple
let's do
um
yes so that's it
yeah
oh yes there's no no results in it
that's a bit stronger
okay centers because for example there
are some results
yeah but not so the the strong ones yes
foreign
between where the problems are solved
a weak region but maybe next time
is what is known about optimal proof
systems in this setting
situation
do you have any suggestions for
something just Beyonce and
make sense in the blankets
it makes sense in the Boolean case it
would mean probably that it would lead
to some lower Bound in
but
[Music]
foreign
correct
every week
foreign